e allez prenez vos sacs on y
[Musique]
va allez Essie
encore jusqu' semaine dernière je
passais ma vie à courir après le temps
je suis là pour vous aider d'accord
essayer de sauver ceux qui n'en avaiit
plus
beaucoup jusqu'au
moment où tout a
basculé content de te revoir chez les
vivants je n'arrive pas à comprendre ce
qui se passe j'ai des
visions je savais qu'il allait
mourir je crois que je peux peux voir
l'avenir New York c'est du grand
n'importe quoi ces derniers
[Musique]
temps New York c'est du grand n'importe
quoi ces derniers temps vous êtes en
danger vous devez descendre cet homme
veut vous tuer pourquoi non mais tu es
qui qu'est-ce qui se
passe je peux voir l'avenir oh c'était
quoi ça elle a rien vu venir c'est pas
c'est pas comme ça que ça
marche j'ai déjà vu cet homme alors
c'est qui Ezéchiel s il était en
Amazonie avec ma mère quand elle étudia
les araignées juste avant qu'elle
Meur attends je te reconnais tu vis dans
mon immeuble c'était toi dans
l'ambulance ouis tu as failli
m'écraser vous trouvez pas ça bizarre
qu'on soit toutes lié les unes aux
autres franchement je dirais que c'est
le truc iz de
jourée tu n'imagines pas ce que ces
filles vont
devenir vous croyez qu'il peut voir
l'avenir il cher les des
[Musique]
choses ir me faire
confiance vous êtes
prêtes maintenant
ouais tu te la racontes quoi peut-être
un peu
ouais